The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this is
the second part of the class,
and this is the last
part of the semester.
So I think we've traveled a lot.
You know, we've seen so many
difficult issues, I think.
And I want to give you credit
for, throughout this semester,
for being so open, honest,
and being able to engage
in difficult issues.
And each time that you
guys are presenting,
you might remember
me nagging you
to get deeper into
personal issues
and not just the abstract.
And the reason is
because, I think
you make a better
case for whatever you
want to argue when you read
your own biography into it.
And I think overall it worked.
I myself, you know, learned so
much throughout the semester
from listening to some of
your own personal discoveries
about yourself, about issues
of race, language, gender,
sexuality.
And I give you lots
of credit for that.
It's risky.
And because before
you came here you
didn't know each other,
obviously, right?
And yet to be able to open
yourself to difficult questions
and to give answers that
were so thoughtful and so--
many of them, I think, I
didn't expect some of you
would, you know, literally come
out in this class, in a way,
right?
So I thought that was
very brave of you.
So I give you my
respect for that.
So with that coming
to end, [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGH]
So we can-- let's do
[INAUDIBLE] that many--
if there are things
that you feel
you will take with
you to the next step,
or that you feel that others
who come after you in this class
might benefit from, anything you
want to share of your learning
experience in this class.
And how you think
you can bridge those
gaps that we've seen, either
in our societies or families.
So I wasn't here last Thursday,
but I watched the video
before class.
And there too, like I was
actually very impressed
by how you guys brought
up personal issues.
But there is a lot
there to work on.
So [INAUDIBLE].
For this class, for these
last 40 minutes or so,
you can have a big
something to bring out.
What would it be?
You ready to get past?
We can go to [? Edna. ?]
AUDIENCE: It's
quicker with words.
Better.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I'm
not sure if I fully
understand what I'm
supposed to say,
but I'll say what
I was thinking.
So for me personally
throughout this class,
I think I realized I like
explored myself and my identity
way more, and I think I was
supposed to ask questions about
myself that I hadn't.
And for me, the main
thing I realized
is like, how uncomfortable
I am with being multiracial.
Like I enjoy being
multiracial, but I
realize that there's parts
of me like that don't really
fit together, and how like
I don't really see myself
as one certain race or ever.
And I think, you know, the
things that helped with that
were like, you know,
our personal essays,
and like definitely
the free writing
assignments that one of the
guest professors had us do.
Like that got pretty deep.
And like I was kind
of like, oh, crap,
I have to write at like
9:30 in the morning
when she first said that.
But then like I really
enjoyed it as it went on.
And I think like
maybe bringing out
more multiracial
topics next year
would be beneficial
to people like me,
like who didn't know that was
like a problem with themselves.
And I think like also a
really interesting topic
that we went over was like--
I think what do we call,
fake-- no, passing.
Passing.
And like how that's
a privilege and like
talking about all the
controversial issues on that.
And I think I
really also thought
about that for this class.
So that's something
I benefited from.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you said faking
instead of passing.
And that remind me of a comment
that Cynthia made back then,
right?
That often when we
think of passing we
think of it as something
which is negative.
But I think [INAUDIBLE] that
point, which I knew very well.
It was very important
that the notion of passing
should not be seen
from that perspective.
And there's a way
that one can think
of passing as a normal
survival strategy, in a way.
So I think we ought to
think of it like-- you
don't have to talk about that.
But you can--
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Say it again?
AUDIENCE: Nothing's-- can
I have another moment?
PROFESSOR: Sure, of course.
We can go to [? Burke ?]
and then come back.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I guess
in terms of our,
I think, it takes a lot of
reflecting and trying to think
about all that we've discussed.
But just sort of a quick note.
One of the things that this
class has sort of solidified
for me is the importance
of conversations.
And so I think most of
the learning that I've
done in this class and other
sort of seminar based classes
sort of pales in
comparison-- or what
I learned in my
technical courses
pales in comparison
to the things
that I've learned in
classes like this.
Because at the end of the day,
I think most of the learning
comes from those around you,
your classmates, the set
of experiences that they have,
more so than what you learn
in these technical classes.
There's a saying that says like,
five years after you graduate,
you won't remember 90%
or whatever of what
you learned in college.
But I think what
you do remember is
these sort of conversations
that boil down
to personal experiences.
And so I think, again,
there is challenge
in this world of
sort of approaching
people who aren't really willing
to have these conversations.
But sort of changing
yourself is the first step.
And I think if everyone sort of
makes or has this realization,
takes a step towards making this
change, it's very idealistic.
But I think the world
would be a better place.
I think that's probably
one thing that I've
gotten from this class.
AUDIENCE: Whoa, man.
Bouncing off what
[? Burke ?] said,
I think one way which I'd
like to see this class grow
is the integration of having
some sort of conversation,
like open discussion
instead of debate,
with someone who does not come
from a similar theological
or ideological background
as most people in this class
to try to see--
to sort of gain practice
in having discussions
with someone who's a
lot different from you
and developing a
common trust and coming
to see each other's
viewpoints in a way that
would be more
informative than what
one could do among a set
of like-minded individuals.
AUDIENCE: So one thing that
I enjoyed about this class,
I can distinctly
remember one class that
literally blew my mind.
I think I turned to somebody
and was like, oh my gosh.
And that was when
we interrogated
what MIT was as an
institution and where we sit
in this hierarchy of social--
in the social
hierarchy in the US.
And I think coming to MIT I was
willing to give the institution
a free pass a lot because
I felt that I was getting
a lot from the experience.
But I think now
that I'm a senior
and all the seniors here are--
last day of classes, you guys.
Now that I'm at this point
where I can think back
on what MIT has done for me
and what and how it functions,
I think I'm better poised
to think more critically
about the institutions
I choose to join
in the future for postgraduate
education and after.
AUDIENCE: So I took this class
as a challenge to myself.
Because at the beginning,
I knew about the prejudices
and stereotypes that
I had been taught
and I wanted to get rid of them.
And I think this class
has helped a lot with that
just by hearing everyone else's
perspectives from the readings,
from looking at the world--
by taking a step back and
looking at things as they are
and not how we were specifically
taught that they are.
And I really appreciate that.
I want to, from here
on, move forward
and try to figure
out how to be an ally
from an Asian-American
perspective.
Because a lot of the times,
Asian-American families
try to be the status quo.
Like my parents have
always taught me to like
try to be, not
explicitly, but implicitly
try to be as white as you can.
And I think that that was
a really difficult lesson
to go through and then come
to a place like MIT which
is so diverse and which has
so many different backgrounds.
And to like come in thinking
there's a hierarchy where
there isn't, and
now going forward
trying to break that down.
AUDIENCE: A lot of what
I was thinking about
during this class
for me personally,
was comparing and contrasting.
Because I come from a very--
I'm from Zimbabwe, so there's
not a lot of diversity.
And this is an entirely
new experience to me.
So a lot of what I was doing was
comparing my past, my history,
my experiences, with
you guys' experiences
and everything around me.
And thinking about, for
instance, in the readings,
how they analyze different
situations, the situation
in America, the
situation in Haiti,
and thinking about where
these things are connected,
how they're different.
What could have been done?
What should be done?
And I think--
I really thought about issues
like this before this class,
and now I'm starting
to think about it more.
Especially in education, I'm
really interested in education
and how we can help teach
people in the future
how to use this skill
that they learn,
how to think about
certain things,
how to approach certain problems
in a way that challenges
them and also challenges
the status quo
and challenges the
hierarchies that are set up.
So personally I think that
that this class definitely
helped me think
a lot more, and I
hope that in future will
help a lot more people think
about their actions, think
about what they're saying,
think about what
they're doing, and think
about how they can
help and how they
can engage their communities.
For instance, I
remember when we're
talking about how we came to
MIT and we might graduate,
and then what are
you going to do
when you go back to the
communities where we come from?
How do you plan to
affect those communities?
Do we go back as experts or
do we go back as one of them?
Do we try to fit in?
Like questions like
that are definitely
things that we should
think about and I think
are very important.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think the biggest thing
for me was like learning
about what we were learning,
but then thinking
back to how I grew up
in like a really white area.
And I was always
taught like there
is one correct way
to speak, there
is like one correct
way to teach kids.
And thinking back now,
with all this information
on how damaging that really
is and how it's not really
about the language and it's
not really about how we speak.
It's more about
marginalizing groups
that might speak that way.
And it's like just thinking
about how my entire school
system was based on like
what they thought was correct
and was telling us what we
should think is correct.
And I think coming
out of this hopefully
we can try to change some of
that in the school systems.
Because it can really affect
how kids view the world as they
grow up.
AUDIENCE: I think one thing
I gained from this class
is kind of, I guess,
verification of the idea
that listening is
very important.
And it's kind of
various ways you
could think about it like just
in the context of this class,
whether it's like listening
to like other people share
their experiences and kind
of really taking it in
and understanding
like how they fit in
within whatever social hierarchy
or whatever kind of issue
we're discussing and seeing
how it's kind of played
a role in their lives.
And kind of seeing how you
could apply it to either better
someone else's
life, like improve
your own kind of interaction
with the world in some way.
Or whether it's listening
in terms of like language.
You talked a lot about
language and kind
of how certain modes of speaking
are somewhat marginalized.
So ensuring that as you
go forward you really
listen to people regardless of
how they present their ideas
or present their thoughts.
Or whether it's like listening
as far as engaging people who
have opposing opinions as you.
Like really understanding
that in order
to strengthen your own
positions and really understand
why it is that you
think the way it is,
you have to be able to listen
to people who kind of think
in a different way than you.
So yeah, I've just seen a lot
of kind of different things
in this class that speaks
of importance of listening.
AUDIENCE: I think what
this class has really
called into question a lot
is this lack of analysis
of my racial background.
Because I'm
Japanese-American it's
not really something that I'm
forced to address all the time,
because no one's really calling
that much attention to it.
Because neither one of
those groups is really
that attacked in modern society
for being a racial group.
And something I didn't
really think about
is like, my mom is an immigrant.
I didn't really
address that ever
because no one was calling to
question her immigration here.
And that also leads to
a lot of like relating
to the opinions of other
people, and especially
like my very conservative
extended family
and how their opinions
about certain things
such as immigration
are reliant on people
being of certain races and
being from certain places.
Because it just
[? poisons ?] something that
they've ever seen
negatively about my family,
but it is something that's the
core of why my family exists.
So I think things like that,
like having people address
their own identities and
their own backgrounds
and how that's
affected how they see
everything else and their
interaction with other people,
I think is a really great
part of this course.
AUDIENCE: I'm having trouble
distilling everything down,
but I guess one big
takeaway from this class
was accepting that
there is no one right
way to exist as a human across
like gender, sexuality, race,
class, and things like that.
And that was a
realization that I
think I came to in this class.
And it all goes back
to the importance
of interrogating
your beliefs and why
you think the ways that you do.
And it's really
eye-opening and I
think that's really important
to have to open yourself up
to that.
And it takes like a certain
level of vulnerability.
Like I wasn't expecting to
come out in this class at all.
But I did, because this was
a place where I felt safe
and it was like
really surprising
that I felt so safe
in this environment.
And I think that's
something that we
need to recreate elsewhere.
Another thing that
I would like to take
for this class in the
future is like, there
are people that aren't
seniors taking this class, so
like what do you do now?
What classes do you take next?
Or what actions can you
take because of what
you've learned in this class?
And I think something that
maybe can happen in this class
is thinking about concrete
ways to actually do stuff.
Because you had Professor
Chomsky here on Tuesday
and he said, almost
anything is the answer
to like, what do we do?
So maybe having some
sort of initiative
coming out of this class
to make change maybe just
at MIT or just like
in class [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So kind
of piggybacking off
of what [? Chris said, ?]
I think the most
meaningful
conversations and talks
that we've had for me were when
we talked to professors, people
all over Cambridge, who were
using their own backgrounds,
their own fields of
study, and they're
making tangible changes,
as Chris was saying.
So for example when we watch
like the virtual reality
kind of simulation in terms
of the Israeli-Palestinian
Conflict.
And I feel like those
conversations and the fact
that I have the
privilege of taking
this class in my last semester
has really kind of driven me
to really take action
outside of MIT,
and hopefully in the
future back at MIT,
and to really take that
with me in my specific field
of medicine and how these
various identities can really
affect people's
kind of health care.
And that's life or death.
And so I feel like that has
really eye-opening for me
and that's kind of
driven me to action.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think for me,
from this class has
made me more aware of how
many things I don't do.
For example, what I didn't know
about the Haitian Revolution
that occurred, and
I didn't really
question it during the time.
But it's all the
things that we aren't
taught just because a lot
of the history that we learn
is taught from like a very
Westernized perspective.
So I feel like it's very
important that this class
teaches that there's always
many ways to do certain things
and there's many things
that aren't necessarily
[? wrong ?] just because I
guess society just doesn't want
us to know about these things.
So then we go [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I think similar to
what [? Herman ?] was saying,
I think this class is
really about the idea
of taking action.
And a lot of our
readings like, passivity
was just there all the time.
People, I remember in
[? Benito ?] [? Soreno ?] where
the captain was just like,
oh, that's really strange,
but I guess that's just
the way things are.
So it's like-- he noticed
that things are wrong
but he didn't do
anything with them.
So I think just trying
to take action and--
many of you mentioned
interrogating yourself
is an important way to do it.
And I really liked the
first assignment, which
was a linguistic autobiography.
And I felt that just thinking
of my whole life in terms
of the languages
I grew up reading,
writing, and how they
were presented to me,
was a really good way just
to look into my own self.
What I think would be better in
future versions of this class
would be maybe talking
together in smaller groups.
I guess it's easier just to
talk about yourself that way
for some people.
They're more
comfortable, I think.
The only time we got to
do that was last Tuesday.
We had Professor
[? Aleman ?] here
and we worked in
groups of three.
That was really cool.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Thank you.
I think-- so also you mean
like [INAUDIBLE],, you know?
So what Chris said we can try
together, because this class
I hope will be offered
many, many, many, many times
again here [INAUDIBLE].
And actually we're
thinking of next year
I might do with [INAUDIBLE].
So from that perspective,
maybe you guys
could share with
me what you think
could be done to implement
what you guys said
in terms of taking this
knowledge into action?
Because throughout
the semester I
was struggling with what
kind of projects do I assign?
Because I often felt it would
be nice to do a project that
puts you guys in the world,
not just writing an essay,
you know?
And I try to see whether
something could come up
spontaneously from you
that you'd go and say,
I will do this.
So how would you advise me
in next cycle of this course
to make that happen?
You know?
To do projects maybe throughout
the semester or maybe
[INAUDIBLE] or optional projects
that will really turn knowledge
into action?
OK, so [? Estrella ?] and
then [INAUDIBLE],, and then
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So maybe
some things like--
I still think you
should have the essays,
because at least for
me they were pretty
beneficial in exploring myself.
But maybe instead of having like
the essay revision-- although I
think like revising
essays is important,
I think it could be done
throughout your essay process
instead.
And maybe like
putting in a project
where you have to
create like a policy
or like a lesson plan
or something like that
and then present that.
And maybe even have a
plan of action of who you
would go to talk to about this.
Because I think if
you just come up
with a plan it can be pretty,
you know, philosophical or just
like, just an idea and it
will never be done with it.
But like, what would
be your next step?
Now you have an idea,
how do you implement it?
And then also something I forgot
to mention before I thought
was really useful
about this class
was when we went
to go to the movies
all together on a Saturday.
And at first I was
like, oh, crap.
Now I have to like
allot a lot of time.
But I actually
really enjoyed that
and was hoping the
conversation would keep going.
So maybe having more
things outside the class.
Because I think it's really
hard to explore all the things
that you want to do
in an hour and a half.
So like maybe having
somewhere like--
I don't know what types
of places you can go to,
but maybe going to, you know,
an inner city school in Boston
together and like seeing
how it's taught there
and what you would change.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's good to hear,
actually, because one thing
that I'm struggling
with [? Fox ?] because
of [INAUDIBLE] is to see whether
we could change the format.
Instead of having
an hour and a half
to having once a
week for three hours.
And in the past I
tried that, but because
of the schedule of MIT it's
a bit hard for students
to enroll for a three hour
class as an undergraduate.
So we stepped away from that.
But now we know whether
we should do that,
and then maybe three hours
we could go someplace else.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
that may be beneficial.
I know like negotiation at
Sloan does it at like Thursday
at like 5:00 or
something like that.
So it's hard to schedule
like a three hour class
during the day, but if you
do it as a night section.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
OK, thank you for saying
that, because I'll
report back to [? Fox ?] and
we will see what [INAUDIBLE]..
So it was [? Lena ?]
then [? Sarah ?] and then
[? Jackie. ?]
AUDIENCE: Well, it
was related directly
to what she just
said about time.
It's just like a short thing.
But having a class at
5:00 will be difficult
because like no athletes
can participate.
You know, because they
practice from 5:00 to 7:00.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There's another section at
7:00 I'm pretty sure, so.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
classes from 7:00 to 10:00.
PROFESSOR: 7:00 to
10:00, yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We were talking-- [? Lena ?]
was talking about projects.
And I think that could
definitely work in this course.
I think one thing that
I've really wanted
is to be able to effect
change within the context
of this course and sort
of have a reason to do so.
And based on the readings, I
would like to go to into school
and say like, let me try my hand
at teaching kids in this way
and see if it actually works.
So if you wanted to
organize that sort of thing,
it could be cool to also
work in small groups
and maybe diversify--
I mean, we have a ton
of new courses in here.
But I think there's a lot
to be gained by going out
into the real world.
And I think--
I mean this is just
me agreeing, but I
think a three hour course
would be a good decision.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[? Sarah. ?]
AUDIENCE: So I think
just my idea stems
from what [? Collin ?]
said about talking
with someone with a different
ideological perspective
than yourself.
So maybe like having
students go in like groups
of two out into the world
and maybe interview someone
or share some of the information
around like [INAUDIBLE]..
But if it was like one of them
was revolutionary [INAUDIBLE]..
Did you ever learn?
[INAUDIBLE] Something
along those lines.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
So going back to the last point.
So in terms of
going to schools, I
have some good news,
which is that I think
I shared that article with you
about this new program that's
being launched in the
[? bottom of ?] the school,
the [INAUDIBLE] program.
And [? Vivian ?] [? Tam, ?]
actually she is ethnically
Chinese.
And she actually launched this
program in Chinese-English
in Cambridge that is doing
really well from what I here.
And then she's also
responsible for launching
this Creole-English
[? studies ?] program.
And she's offered that if
they're students in this class
and other classes
at MIT, they want
to come and volunteer and take
advantage of that new program
in terms of doing
any research that's
socially based or
empirically based,
or even like to do
with measuring students
learning gains, she would
be happy to work with you.
There is one student in my
other class, [INAUDIBLE],,
who is going to get
out twice and was
going to be going on a
weekly basis to the meetings
to try to understand how they're
creating this new program.
We're going to be, I
think, half kids who
speak Creole and half
don't speak Creole,
and it's going to
be truly bilingual.
So you get American
or other ethnicities,
as many English and Creole, and
you get each of the Creole kids
be included also learning
English and developing English.
So I think it is really
a very radical move
for the [? government. ?] We've
had other programs of that
sort, but never one involving
a [? non-imperial ?] language.
Typically it's Spanish-English,
French-English,
Chinese-English.
But it's the first
time that they're
doing one that includes
a language like Haitian
Creole, that's been over
the years, as you know,
stigmatized in various ways.
So we're excited.
We've had some pushback,
including pushback
from Haitian parents,
who some of them
would prefer to have
it in French, as you
can imagine, right?
They don't speak
French, but it's
a typical neo-colonial
[INAUDIBLE]
into an superior
language, so to speak.
But I think there's been some
good progress on that front.
In fact, Noam Chomsky
was here Tuesday.
He had an interview which
I put on my Facebook page.
[? In fact, ?] [? I sent it ?]
[? to you. ?] Where it was me
and him.
And I since have
[INAUDIBLE] [? interview, ?]
but it was [INAUDIBLE].
But I mean it's
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
It's New Mexico, but she
grew up in California.
And it was a very interesting
exchange between the two of us,
in terms of listening about
the importance of promoting
these local languages
or really collaboration
of the experience [INAUDIBLE].
So I think that this
is a good suggestion.
It's a very good suggestion.
And since [? Harold ?] has some
background [? participation, ?]
as you saw, with a project
involving virtual reality,
that might be another part where
you can do action [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: With just based
off what you said like with
the [? Fox ?] [? Harold ?]
computation part,
I thought it was really
interesting like learning about
what he's doing.
But I think if there was like--
I don't know if this is
where you were going.
But like if I think there
was a more requirement
to do more
computation-based things,
like I probably would have
strayed away from this class.
Because like I'm not like
the stereotypical major here.
Like I'm a business
major, but I think
I would've been like
slightly intimidated
if there was like a
CMS-type project in here.
So maybe like making that one of
the facets of what you can do,
but not a requirement.
PROFESSOR: OK, I see.
OK, that's good, yeah.
Yeah, good to hear, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think
also taking advantage
of the learning styles of
the students in the class
can be interesting.
So maybe doing more
creative projects
or doing projects
that people feel
like allow them to
use their best skills
and actually have
fun, I feel like.
PROFESSOR: So tell
me, [? Cynthia. ?]
If you could have done a
project that was creative,
what would you have done?
Just to get a sense of what we
could think of in the future?
AUDIENCE: Just off the fly,
I maybe would have made like
a 10-foot tall papier-mache
person and written like,
I don't know, stuff all over
it and put it in [? lobby ?]
[? 10. ?]
AUDIENCE: Like negative
comments or like?
AUDIENCE: No, anything.
Just stuff like--
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
OK.
And then they would have to
have a part that includes
communication of some sort.
So how would you do that?
So you would do that and then
perhaps have other people
describing what you did and
the mission or what you've done
and the objective and
[? strength that ?]
[? accompanies? ?]
AUDIENCE: I mean, if it
was just like a black body
or like a brown
body of some sort,
you could even just
leave markers and stuff
for other people to
put messaging on it
I feel like would be--
like I think art is a
great way to give people
an entry into having
those conversations.
And it would be an art project.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
Excellent.
I'm so glad this is being
recorded so that we have this.
No, really.
We have this I can watch it with
[? Fox ?] [? Harold ?] and then
we can plan around it.
This is great.
Actually, anyone has concrete
suggestions like that?
AUDIENCE: So our class
is one of those--
I don't-- maybe you're taking
it, psychology, gender,
and race?
No?
OK.
It's taught by a psychologist
who works in the local area.
Her first name is [? Chevy. ?]
I forget her last name.
But part of the class is
like during mock training
on how to present cultural
awareness presentations where
you go with--
you basically form
a group of students
and kind of teach
the other students
who are role playing as like
members of a college frat
or like sixth graders out of
a local Boston public school,
about like how some things
that they may be doing
could be disparaging
to minority groups.
And it could be interesting,
having a conversation with her
to see like what
things she incorporates
into those presentations,
and if that
would be useful inside
of [INAUDIBLE] matters.
PROFESSOR: OK, that
would be useful.
Could be very useful.
[? Lena? ?]
AUDIENCE: No, I was [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: With the
wiki that I think
was a new thing this
semester, I think--
just another way for
us to communicate
like as students would be great.
Because just like maybe
someone said something in class
that was really interesting
and you only have their email.
Like it's hard to
get in contact,
so maybe another like
opt-in way to have like--
PROFESSOR: So the wiki
didn't really work?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Nah.
PROFESSOR: Why
didn't the wiki work?
AUDIENCE: It's hard.
AUDIENCE: It's not
a good platform.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: The wiki is
not a good platform.
Open course review here, the
wiki is not a good platform.
I heard that as well
in my other class.
The students said, we
don't like the wiki.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I never used it.
AUDIENCE: It's
not user-friendly.
AUDIENCE: What about like a
slack channel or something,
like where you can be more
communicative but also like
[INAUDIBLE]?
Or a group in like Facebook?
Like something
that we already all
use and wouldn't have
to go out of our way to.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Who had
their hand raised?
Was there a hand
raised over here?
Was it [? Shope? ?]
Was your hand raised?
No?
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So you're asking what
kind of projects, right?
So from the teaching
perspective,
I think after the
classes last week I'm
learning about opened
and fixed mindset.
Something that would have
been interesting as a project
would be to create a
curriculum, like just
a lecture or a workshop for
an age group, whatever age.
It could be college,
it could be lower.
And kind of trying to
implement the like teaching
techniques that we learn to
foster a more open mindset.
That would have been a
cool project to explore.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK, great.
OK, so [? Fanny, ?]
[? Dana, ?] and [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Mine is off of that.
AUDIENCE: So you go first.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I think that would
be a good idea.
Also, we could still enlist
the help of the professor
for any of these lectures.
Because I think that will give
us a little more, you know,
oomph when we actually go
into these schools and say,
you know, we'd like to
bring this plan to you.
Because we have
professor backing.
We have this whole slew
of research behind us.
AUDIENCE: Another cool thing
that you could do about
like community outreach is--
I know one time a couple weeks
ago in Amphibious Achievement
we had a bunch of people
from Chocolate City come in.
And also there's a group, like
something, something Latinas.
And I don't know--
AUDIENCE: Mujeres Latinas?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So they came in and
Chocolate City came in.
And--
PROFESSOR: You have to give
some background about Chocolate
City and Amphibious Achievement,
and make it self-contained.
AUDIENCE: Right, sorry.
PROFESSOR: So that
way if people don't
know who you're referring to.
AUDIENCE: So Amphibious
Achievement is--
it's a program at MIT and
we work with Boston public
high schoolers.
And it's like an academic
mentorship program,
but also we just
like work with them
to try to build
their confidence,
and we also help them apply to
college and things like that.
And then Chocolate
City is like just
like a living group
here on campus,
and it's like
African-American men.
And then-- say it again.
AUDIENCE: Mujeres Latinas.
AUDIENCE: That's a group
of like Latina women.
And so they came in to
talk to the high schoolers
in Amphibious Achievement, and
we just had like a discussion
about how they feel about what
they've been told they can
and cannot do because
of like who they are.
And it was really, really
interesting for everybody.
And I think that would
be something cool to do.
PROFESSOR: Do you
have a Facebook page?
AUDIENCE: We do.
It is called
Amphibious Achievement.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Thank you.
So actually would
Facebook be a better way
to communicate
instead of the wiki?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, way better.
PROFESSOR: Way better.
So maybe next year then we
should create a Facebook page
for the course.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A page for
the course, and then
a messaging group
for the students.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
That's a good idea.
All right, maybe one of you
could create a Facebook page
for this group, and that way
you guys could keep in touch.
And given what [? Fanny ?]
just explained,
you could do other projects
combining your strengths
and others together to
bring actual change.
That may be
something you can do.
But you'd have to be
responsible for it.
Yes.
[? Collin? ?]
AUDIENCE: Bouncing
off your idea,
I think it'd be really
interesting like,
noticing how one
[? product ?] option would
be like an emancipatory literacy
class presentation or something
like that, where you take a
certain section of literature,
maybe just one book,
like Madame Ovary,
and dissect the ways in
which the society in which it
is embedded create
the themes within it.
Like major things
that are in Madame
Ovary is like centered
on this one woman who
is like married in the
countryside of France
back in like the 1900s or 1800s.
And she gets really depressed
because she has nothing to do.
And just explaining
that like, she
has no options for employment
and is stuck at home
because that's what was expected
of women back in that day.
And like dissecting both
that cultural phenomenon
and like examining how that
may play out in today's terms
with different
patterns in society.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good, good.
So it's 10:55, so we'll get
[? Lena ?] the last word.
AUDIENCE: Oh, jeez.
Wow, OK.
So something that I
was thinking about
was what you had said about
having like an art project.
And I realized I'm
not artistic at all,
so I was trying to figure
out what I would do
if there was an art assignment.
And I was thinking about
something that's in a show
where like you put yourself
up, like you stand up there,
and then you have like
a projector screen
and you write
words on it of what
you don't like about yourself.
And that could be
like, instead of
like what we don't
like about ourselves,
like things we've been
told about ourselves based
off our race or based on
our gender or sexuality.
And also having things you
would rather have been said.
Because what I really liked this
class was the self-exploration.
PROFESSOR: All right, then.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]